vi è mai capitato di partecipare alla
conferenza o una lezione o più
semplicemente sentire parlare qualcuno
che vi si è venuta in mente una domanda
ma che dopo una lunga riflessione
abbiate deciso di non porre la domanda
voce alta e che dopo pochi secondi
qualcun altro nel pubblico abbia alzato
la mano e abbia posto esattamente la
stessa domanda che era venuta in mente a
voi la stessa cosa vi può essere
successa con un'idea un'idea per un
prodotto per un progetto per una ricerca
per un marchio
io sono sempre stato molto interessato a
cercare di capire quali sono i
meccanismi alla base del fatto che la
stessa idea possa emergere
contemporaneamente in due luoghi diversi
ma anche mi interessano molto tutti i
processi per i quali un idea è in grado
di viaggiare da un luogo a un altro e
quelli che determinare il cambiamento
delle idee nel tempo il fenomeno per cui
una stessa idea emerge in due luoghi
diversi contemporaneamente
indipendentemente e detto convergenza
convergenza un concetto fondamentale non
solo per le idee ma anche nell'ambito
dell'evoluzione biologica
a dire il vero è anche molto importante
per lo studio del nostro passato del
nostro passato remoto
in particolare al momento nell'ambito
della ricerca sulle nostre origini
uno degli argomenti più caldi è
sicuramente quello dell'interazione tra
noi omosapiens è uno dei nostri parenti
più prossimi
l'uomo di neanderthal cerchi recenti ci
dicono che tra questi due gruppi
c'è stato un flusso genico ovvero uno
scambio di informazione biologica che ci
sono progetti internazionali che stanno
cercando di capire se oltre a questo
flusso genico ci sia stato anche un
flusso culturale ovvero uno scambio di
cultura
in altre parole si sta cercando di
capire se il cambiamento tecnologico che
vediamo in europa per esempio tra 45 e
40 mila anni fa sia dovuto a un
trasferimento di cultura a una
sostituzione dell'uomo di neanderthal da
parte del l'uomo sapiens oppure ad altri
processi quali la convergenza
l'italia gioca un ruolo chiave in questa
ricerca
oggi qui ci troviamo a schio siamo tra i
colli berici e monti lessini nel cuore
di una regione fondamentale per
comprendere il processo di interazione
tra noi i neanderthal in europa
settentrionale cosa che vedete qua nella
foto dell'ingresso della grotta di
fumane un sito archeologico chiave per
comprendere questi fenomeni
abbiamo pero capito che se ci interessa
capire che a fondo come le idee cambiano
nel tempo non ci possiamo solo basare
sul concetto di convergenza ma dobbiamo
anzi concentrarci su tutti i processi
complementari quelli di trasmissione
della cultura quando vogliamo imparare
qualcosa di nuovo sul mondo oltre fare
affidamento sulle nostre capacità
personali
il modo migliore che abbiamo è
sicuramente copiare dagli altri imitare
gli altri per apprendere e imparare è
sicuramente una delle strategie più
efficaci che abbiamo messo a punto a
livello di specie imitare gli altri è
talmente innato in noi che abbiamo messo
a punto anche una serie di strumenti per
proteggere l'originalità delle idee come
copyright
allo stesso modo però siamo consapevoli
che non esiste cultura all'interno di un
individuo isolato che la cultura è
necessariamente un fatto sociale e che
emerge solamente al termine di un
processo cumulativo di interazione e
scambio tra individui e gruppi e che in
questi momenti di interazione e scambio
della cultura muta ed evolve quello che
vi sto dicendo oggi
è un esempio perfetto perché non si
tratta di demi e ma sono elaborazioni
basate su intuizioni di altri
ricercatori in questo caso grandissimi
ricercatori luigi luca cavalli sforza
purtroppo recentemente scomparso e
marcos fehlmann avevano già capito nel
1981 che la trasmissione della cultura
può essere studiata analizzata
quantificata è compresa al pari della
trasmissione genetica
questo concetto è stato ulteriormente
formalizzato qualche anno dopo da robert
boyle e peter rich i quali hanno
definito la cultura come informazione
che viene trasmessa parallelamente ma
non sempre indipendentemente dall
informazione genetica
se però quest'ultima gode solo di una
trasmissione verticale quindi fra
genitori e figli
la cultura può essere trasmessa anche da
persone che non sono imparentati al fra
di loro
abbiamo quindi sempre una dimensione
verticale o meglio in questo caso
obliqua tra una generazione e la
generazione successiva ma abbiamo anche
un fitto scambio orizzontale tra
individui che fanno parte della stessa
generazione
chiaramente siamo in un ambito evolutivo
quindi non tutta l'informazione
culturale è uguale
c'è un tipo di informazione che
sottoposta a un vero e proprio fenomeno
di selezione a un processo di scelta
sistematico a livello di società
possiamo per esempio scegliere di
imitare un modello all'interno della
nostra società del nostro gruppo nel
paleolitico si poteva trattare del
miglior cacciatore oggi molto più
probabilmente potrebbe trattarsi del
miglior calciatore possiamo anche
scegliere per esempio di apprendere e
riprodurre una forma perché siamo
convinti che svolga meglio una precisa
funzione rispetto a un'altra
possiamo decidere di imitare quello che
fa la maggioranza delle persone attorno
a noi possiamo invece optare
anticonformista possiamo decidere di
fare esattamente l'opposto
e se da un lato abbiamo tutta questa
serie di processi selettivi
possiamo invece avere un processo di
trasmissione della cultura totalmente
libero da scelte sistematiche in questo
caso scegliamo piuttosto casualmente
cosa riprodurre degli atteggiamenti che
vediamo attorno a noi per esempio il
modo di vestirci e possiamo in questo
modo contribuire alla formazione di mode
nel tempo che vengono poi via via
abbandonate e sostituite da altre 9
quello che è certo è che gli episodi di
trasmissione ripetuti della cultura
portano alla diffusione della cultura
stessa la cultura si diffonde
principalmente in due modi
uno è detto di diffusione dei mica
ovvero in questo caso la cultura si
muove seguendo i piedi delle persone
abbiamo un fenomeno migratorio lo
spostamento di un popolo o di un
segmento di una popolazione e le loro
idee e la loro cultura
segue esattamente il loro movimento in
questo caso la variabilità genetica è un
ottimo elemento che possiamo usare se
due popolazioni sono molto simili dal
punto di vista genetico e dal punto di
vista culturale
possiamo andare a indagare se
effettivamente le migrazioni hanno avuto
un ruolo in questo diciamo dall'aperto
port opposta dello spettro abbiamo
invece un processo di diffusione
culturale in cui le informazioni e la
cultura sono libere di diffondersi senza
e ci sia necessariamente il movimento di
popolazioni in questo caso dobbiamo
pensare a qualcosa di più simile a un
enorme continentale telefono senza fili
esattamente come nel gioco che
conosciamo tutti le regole su cui si
basa questo modello sono due e sono
semplicissime la prima è che più lunga e
la catena di individui che si passano
un'informazione più è probabile che in
ciascuno di questi passaggi emergano
le varianti delle mutazioni o degli
errori la seconda è che più lunga è
questa catena di individui che è facile
che alla fine due individui che si
trovano agli estremi opposti e lontani
tra loro siano dei territori di
un'informazione più diversa rispetto a
due individui che si trovano invece
vicini in questo caso non useremo la
genetica ma la geografia è un buon
predittore della diversità culturale
negli ultimi 40 anni ci sono stati
moltissimi studi che si sono occupati di
questo argomento ancora una volta
partendo dalle intuizioni di cavalli
sforza in questo caso con albert
ammerman nel 1971
sì ero posto la domanda se per caso la
diffusione dell'agricoltura in europa
fosse dovuta a fenomeni migratori fino
al movimento di popoli oppure fosse
arrivata attraverso diffusione culturale
e ha concluso che si trattava del primo
caso dagli anni 70 oggi come vi dicevo
sono tantissimi gli studi che si sono
occupati di questo problema e questo
approccio è stato usato solo per citarne
alcuni dei più recenti per esempio sulla
diffusione della musica e degli
strutture musicali o la diffusione della
variabilità linguistica oppure l'impatto
dell'appartenenza linguistica sulla
distribuzione di varianti di una singola
fiaba e proprio sulle fiabe i miei
colleghi ed io
recentemente abbiamo deciso di
concentrarci perché è proprio le fiabe
prima di tutto perché le fiabe sono un
elemento fondamentale e intimo del
bagaglio di ciascuno di noi
quando nasciamo ciascuno di noi riceve
un corredo genetico e da quel momento in
poi comincia a ricevere anche un corredo
di fiabe inoltre sin dalla pubblicazione
delle prime raccolte dei fratelli grimm
gli studiosi di folklore gli etnologi si
sono subito posti la domanda del perché
della somiglianza impressionante tra
strutture narrative personaggi e
messaggi contenuti nelle storie che
venivano via via scoperte documentate
nei luoghi più diversi
proprio per questo abbiamo deciso di
guardare la distribuzione di 596 tipi di
fiabe desunti dal catalogo più grande e
completo ad oggi disponibile il catalogo
di arn thomson reuters
come ogni catalogo non è esente da
distorsioni ma consapevoli di ciò
abbiamo cercato di limitarne gli effetti
e siamo comunque andati avanti e abbiamo
contato il numero di fiabe condivise tra
coppie di popolazioni distribuite in
europa e in asia
e tra le stesse coppie di popolazioni
abbiamo misurato la distanza genetica e
la distanza geografica quello che
abbiamo trovato è che abbassa scala
geografica
l'impatto del movimento di popolazione
delle migrazioni è ancora visibile nella
distribuzione dei tipi di fiaba questo
vuol dire che in un'area grande più o
meno come l'europa
le persone si sono spostate e hanno
portato con sé le proprie storie
trasmettendole nel luogo di arrivo la
scala più grande in indicativamente
sopra 5 6mila chilometri
purtroppo le tracce di questo effetto si
perdono e quindi siamo costretti a
pensare che la diffusione culturale
abbia avuto un ruolo preponderante
come vediamo in questo caso come tanti
altri
l'elemento nemico genetico biologico
elemento culturale
non si escludono a vicenda
anzi si compenetrano si mischiano sono
in effetti e guardarci bene due facce di
una stessa medaglia due faccini
scindibili questa medaglia è quella
dell'evoluzione umana chiama parte
biologica e una parte culturale ma è
anche quella del cammino dell'uomo fuori
dall'africa un cammino lungo e fatto di
flussi costanti afor una volta biologici
e culturale e più studiamo questo
cammino piacere diamo conto che in
effetti l'insieme di movimento scontro
ma soprattutto incontro e scambio
sciuto la frana del nostro passato e
forse di questo tessuto può essere fatta
la chiave per capire il nostro presente
grazie
[Applauso]